what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we discuss the origins powers and feats
of the strongest characters in comics
and this week we're discussing scar the
son of the hulk which is kind of
astounding that we've never ever talked
about this guy before but scar was
created by greg pack and john romita jr
and first appeared in what if planet
hulk number one in 2007 so to understand
what happens in this story we first have
to talk about what happened during the
actual planet hulk event which is one of
the best hulk stories ever written and i
have covered it in full on the channel
if you guys want to go over and check
that out what and
tim what are you doing hmm
oh
i'm just eating some cereal damn are
these all your fans yes tim these are
all the members of the rob core by the
way rob porter this is tim my brother
tim this is the rob corey what's up
i don't get how you have so many fans
you know
you've been doing this for eight years
you got all these fans all these people
love you i've known you for 37 years and
i still don't like you
uh what are you eating um
this is magic spoon oh is magic spoon
sponsoring the video yeah they're the
ones who were sponsoring the video
though how is it they're good man you
know i like them um they're like a keto
grain-free
gluten-free cereal
they're really really good this is the
honey graham one this is one that i like
most um
i mean it's good if you're on low-carb
right so they've got like zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein like
four net grams of carbs per serving so
it comes out to be about 140 calories
per serving
but it's really really good um yeah okay
um okay well then let me give him the
whole rundown on it i would check it out
i mean i just got it i don't know if
you've had it at all lord knows you
could eat a little a little healthier
dude really
i'll tell you something
37 years living in this world
this dude okay dude it's time for you to
go healthy hey
i can talk to the rob corp too i can
talk to the fans no you can't either
they don't want to go
now you're not the right you're not do
not listen to him no you're not letting
him always
yeah make sure you guys check out magic
spoon
okay having said that if you guys want
to live a healthier lifestyle you guys
want to eat healthier foods then make
sure you click the link in the
description and grab a variety pack so
you guys can try today and be sure to
use a promo code on the screen at
checkout so you guys can get five
dollars off any order and magic spoon is
so confident in their product that it's
backed with a 100 happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so again make sure you guys check
out the link in the description or use
the promo code on the screen now so you
can get five dollars off your order and
now let's continue on with our video so
to make a long story extremely short
after hulk destroys las vegas following
the detonation of a gamma bomb which
causes him to temporarily go crazy a
group called the illuminati which
consists of doctor strange reed richards
tony stark professor xavier namor and
blackvult of the inhumans who sucks they
decide the hulk is too dangerous to live
on earth so they trick him into getting
into a spaceship which they intend to
send to an uninhabited planet where he
can live in peace and not hurt anybody
hulk however lands on a war-torn planet
called zakar overthrows the planet's
leader falls in love with a warrior
named kaira who becomes pregnant with
hulk's child now the people of sicar's
capital are in the process of turning
the hulk ship that brought him to the
planet into a monument which is going to
be dedicated to him when the
self-destruct sequence initiates blowing
up the city and killing kaira this of
course makes the hulk extremely pissed
off and he returns to earth to get his
revenge on those responsible for kaira's
death kicking off the whole world war
hulk storyline but this issue of what if
imagines an alternate timeline where it
was hulk and not kyra that was killed in
the explosion and is pretty predictable
from there kyra goes to earth destroys
the avengers leaves the earth in ruins
and then returns to sakhar but when we
flash forward 21 years later and we see
hulk and kyra's son tell his mother that
something is finished we're talking
about the monument of the hulk that the
citizens of sakhar were basically
building and that's all we see of scar
during his first appearance now a few
months later we see scar actually get
introduced to the main marvel continuity
in world war hulk number five where we
see in the last panel that scar is
rising from a pile of green goo on the
planet's car now later on scar would get
his own series where we basically
learned that he actually survived inside
of a cocoon and after he emerges from it
becomes a ridiculously capable warrior
eventually defeating a barbarian warlord
that seeks to rule cicard now scar
himself is thought by the planet's
people to be their savior but after he
claims the old power an ancient source
of magic belonging to his mother's tribe
scar becomes a danger to everybody on
the planet now when the silver surfer
arrives to announce that galactus is
coming to sakhar to feed on it he tells
scar that if he allows his people to
escape and his planet to be consumed
that the old power within the planet
will keep galactus satisfied for a
hundred thousand years which means that
billions of lives would be saved now
scar refuses and the two of them
basically battle with the silver surfer
winning and stripping scar of the old
power and forcing it back to the
planet's court but in doing so he dooms
the residence of sikar now this weakens
the silver surfer and scar is able to
easily defeat him and then implant him
with an obedience disc turning the
surfer into scar slave now scar's mother
returns to life and then tries to make
him see the error of his destructive
ways but he still refuses to see reason
so she strips some of the old power now
in a last-ditch effort to change scar's
mind the silver surfer imbues him with
the power cosmic and sends him to face
galactus now once he has the knowledge
of galactus power the surfer restores
the old power but scar once again
refuses to evacuate the planet instead
saying that if galactus tries to consume
sikar then he'll draw upon the old power
from every corner of the universe where
it exists which would make galactus
become addicted to it and then increases
hunger a thousand times over so every
planet in the universe will inevitably
be consumed seeing how crazy her son is
kyra banishes scar from sakhar and
allows herself and the planet to be
consumed now this is quite a bit about
his origin so let's get to scar's powers
and as you might expect as the son of
hulk scar has immense superhuman
strength from the moment he broke out of
the cocoon that birthed him scar was
able to kill an entire horde of monsters
from sakhar he was also proven
significantly stronger than the thing
and was able to pierce dr doom's armor
with one swing of his sword now his
punches were strong enough to draw blood
from namor knock the hulk off his feet
cause earthquakes when he punched the
ground and he was somehow able to punch
through a wormhole and all of that was
without the aid of the old power which
basically enhances his strength to
ridiculous levels when he was amped by
the old power scar was able to send the
juggernaut into outer space with one
punch and was able to send world breaker
hulk flying into a different state with
one of his punches of course when
thinking about the hulk his strength
goes hand in hand with his incredible
durability and his son definitely
inherited this trait from his father as
well and he has some absolutely
ridiculous durability feats so he
survived swimming through molten lava
and his laugh as he absorbed the blast
from three dragons scar is also tanked
punches from some of the strongest
characters in all of marvel comics
including juggernaut ares the god of war
thor and the hulk he was unaffected by
attacks from the silver surfer one of
the most powerful characters in the
universe he's also survived being
punched into outer space by world
breaker hulk and falling back to earth
so it's pretty much impossible to
actually harm this guy even so he does
possess a regenerative healing factor
much like his father and is able to
instantly heal from basically any injury
including being stabbed with a sword as
well as by dakin the son of wolverine
now like i said earlier scar is at his
most powerful when he has access to the
old power and he has pulled off some
really really impressive feats using the
old power for one he's able to summon
lava from the ground to incinerate
multiple individuals he was able to
change his body into stone which
suggests some level of molecular
manipulation scar also possesses some
measure of enhanced perception as he's
able to see the location of people on
the other side of the planet and
suggested he would be able to kill them
instantly if he wanted to on one
occasion scar was able to use the old
power to absorb the energy of a nuclear
meltdown and on another instance he was
able to deliver a blast that dispelled
thor while thor was amped with gamma
radiation he also had enough strength to
impale the world breaker hulk on a spike
and most impressively he moved the
tectonic plates of earth's crust and if
you consider the amount of damage that
someone could do to the planet by moving
its tectonic plates around well he could
cause multiple disasters and likely rip
the planet itself apart so the fact that
he could just destroy the world plus the
fact that he's gone up against
characters like thor silver surfer and
bruhlbreaker hulk and held his own
definitely earns him a place on our
beyond omega level characters list but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end i'm surprised
it took us so long to do this let me
know what you guys think down in the
description tim i know you're still
watching this do not show up in my
videos again and i will catch you all
later
peace